forehead
he said no one judged about us someone
who is this believing God is a criminal
what what is the crime of the purchase
now
I don't need to have a fight with you
about it it's a discussion
is one
there we go
so
no what is the criteria we're going to
utilize to determine what is right or is
wrong what is the criteria oh each and
individual person's views I guess so
enough objectivity
no it doesn't because I subjected me in
you could be wrong you agree with that
yeah so there's point to speaking about
you no I'm not I believe that it's right
from God I could be wrong but you can't
no because from God there's no room yeah
it's illogical if you stand here
I haven't even finished my point you
said no but clearly you made up your
mind before you came here because if
you're a man of honor and dignity
yeah
yeah okay my point here is irrational
for you to come to criticize something
which you know
I made a point which was that me as a
person open-minded personally
appointments
it's not letting me finish my point you
interrupt me first
yeah
I mean we can repeat it
I forgot which was that all of that
right up to the point where you have the
comma we could all sign up to everybody
okay but then in my view there is a
difference between as you've said
righteousness is a subjective point of
view
as I said it's a subjective point of
view and different people who have
different things about what a writer
wants I'm not talking about crimes
obviously Raiders obviously murder is
wrong how do you know that in your
opinion in your opinion or is it
absolutely in my opinion rape as well
when can it ever be right no no wait do
you say Activity
is it is right is there anything
absolute race nobody should ever take
away anybody else's Freedom I'm asking
you that person videos
cool and mental is there anything
absolute right that's my question to you
absolute truth is there anything else
from any complete absolute truth I can't
answer it I don't know
for me maybe not
if if for you there's no absolute truth
so therefore to be consistent you cannot
say rape is wrong all the time because
do you have been subjected by me I
clearly can say rape is wrong all the
time that's why we need to believe in
God you become confused.com
which is which was crossing the
boundaries
what is the criteria you are utilizing
to determine what is wrong
for me
what individuality
is right yes you don't listen to
yourself let me teach yourself
Absolutely I'll subjectivity
subjectivity means that when you say
something is wrong according to me as
soon as you say that therefore you are
opening the gate for other people to say
okay wrong to you that's up to you but
you cannot imagine
you cannot impose your opinion on me and
I often do is for rapists little files
but when it comes to Islam believe in
God we say no there's absolute wrong you
know why because the Creator is a truth
when it creates a death to determine
something is wrong nothing can tell you
it's right you understand that's why the
Western world is
okay
[Music]
that's a crime
if you better take care of it let me
give you examples
your parents if your father take took
care of all your life when you grow up
you tell away from your father you just
respect him you disrespect your father
who took care of you all your life
don't disrespect myself
his family took care of him all his life
she's in one his mother everything when
he grows up what he does he disrespects
them is it a good person or a bad person
who disrespect in his parents
but assuming that his parents are good
people and were fair to him yeah some
parents are not good and you need to
walk away from him
his parents
experience
God gave your life gave him life so the
one who gave us everything
yeah I don't believe it okay
it doesn't make me a criminal if I don't
believe in God
the universe gave me life universe
you and me both come from the universe
what is universal but it's the atoms the
molecules
how do we agree to disagree how do you
agree with somebody or have you talked
to somebody that does not believe what
you believe respectfully we'll talk so
and we are talking respect yeah
we're throwing the ball around yeah
rationality
let's analyze that if I tell you this
foreign
everything and you came from a random or
blind matter that doesn't make any sense
the food is lesser complicated than you
if I tell you the phone was made by a
rock if I tell you
would you accept it a rock yeah
it was made out of human engineers no if
you don't know if you look at the phone
and you see there's a structure there is
a guideline there's all that everything
you don't have to see the person who
made it by utilizing your sound
reasoning you know it's impossible
irrational for some people's structure
with the menu with a guideline to come
without a Creator or possess knowledge
and ability and a power Samsung or Apple
it's Apple okay so you believe in apple
you all photos
and I have many Muslim friends and I
respect the way that they go about their
lives in their Humanity but I'm
Different
of course you're white I'm light skin
no problem we're different yeah no
problem we don't want to be the same
if you tell me the universe is created
in order to create something
if you are not existent you are not
existent you cannot create yourself
because you never exist you need
something to be rich existence yes so
the fact that we know universe is
created therefore is
logical a Russian technological that is
beautiful universe is created by itself
because it's called law of
non-construction who doesn't make any
sense okay second thing I don't believe
allows create to begin with so your
argument is forced to begin with
[Music]
so this is something that happened many
many billions of years ago
you're free
that's not righteousness
am I a friend or an enemy yeah am I a
friend what do you want to be
we believe in God Allah
foreign
[Music]
and it should be it should be there
everybody should have the same
opportunity the same opportunities in
life be treated the same right you know
if you break the law if you're a
criminal then you get judged after don't
get shot
of course
it should be should allow me not to feel
like I'm okay
for example if a Muslim comes
the country
therefore okay
but the most just thing to do is
everything the Creator
foreign
[Laughter]